you had a quote where you say people
always ask you why country music when
Britney is this huge pop star and you
say well why did Britney do pop you
raised in Louisiana to me doing pop
music is a much well at the time was a
much more far-fetched dream we were from
this little town in the middle of
nowhere and she says hey I want to go do
what Madonna does I want to go do this
chasing that was a much bigger question
like what's this little girl from
Louisiana gonna do up there with all
these other pop stars so it would have
made much more sense for our you know
from our small town being Louisiana fur
for need to do country could you ever
see Britney crossing over at this point
I think that Britney appreciates all
music but I don't ever see her like
doing a full country album I think that
what she is is more than just music she
is you know she's created a real legacy
and she will experiment with everything
and I hope she does but I think that you
know she's got her niche she knows what
she's doing yeah and you were on her
last album chillin with you yeah any
plans to work together in the future in
the studio I think that it's one of the
things that has to happen naturally
you can't like plan it out and say this
is what we're gonna do we're gonna sing
the song if it was something where we
sat down and we you know wrote something
or if there was a song I'm gonna go we
got to sing this together but it's got
to be a natural thing it can't be for us
you